[Musica]
the field of might
scherzavo
che abbiamo un problema di cambiamento
climatico l'abbiamo capito tutti vero su
questo non ci sono dubbi ne abbiamo un
parlato fino ad adesso il problema vero
sarà diciamo farvi interessare del tema
della finanza perché effettivamente è un
argomento molto astratto imponente
rispetto a quelle che sono le nostre
quotidianità che cosa manca alla finanza
oggi manca il tempo perché il tempo
scorre il tempo è denaro
che cosa facciamo noi per contrastare no
anche nel nostro quotidiano
il cambiamento climatico che ne so
quando vi lavate i denti spegnete
l'acqua quando uscite dalla stanza
spegnete la luce fate la raccolta
differenziata
piuttosto che pagare le tasse andare a
votare
fate beneficenza
di derrate alimentari vestiti
di farmaci brigate molto bene ma
possiamo fare di più dobbiamo fare di
più possiamo fare la differenza con i
nostri acquisti per esempio perché
ricordatevi voi avete il potere del
consumatore con un vostro acquisto un
vostro qui clic
potete fare la differenza perché
equivale a un voto oggi
quando
praticamente voi definite quello che è
un prodotto sostenibile o meno potete
finalmente scegliere e
tenere alto il valore di un brand la sua
reputazione
oppure meno questo ovviamente alle
aziende interessa tantissimo
infatti quando si tratta di definire le
politiche di contrasto alla
decarbonizzazione
oppure il contrasto alla carbonizzazione
oppure alla meta mitigazione degli
impatti ambientali
oggi è necessario comunicare il perché
perché le norme lo richiedono le proprie
ma anche quelle della filiera
circostante e queste dichiarazioni
vengono poi inseriti online e voi le
potete vedere ma non basta non basta
dobbiamo fare molto di più dobbiamo
proprio cambiare paradigma
servono investimenti
servono disinvestimenti da quelle
società che inquinano e di investimenti
in quelle realtà che effettivamente
fanno la differenza e cioè che non
vedono al sistema planetario
i vostri soldi voi dove le mettete le
vostre pensioni il tfr i vostri phone i
vostri risparmi i vostri conti sapete
dove sono appoggiati avete idea se in
qualche modo in maniera diretta o
indiretta vanno a vedere in qualche modo
anche un paese terzo
bene
bilancio queste due sib ricordate viali
perché se ne sentirà parlare sempre di
più gli argini e vomita social and
governance
sono quelli in quegli indicatori che
integrati che nelle politiche aziendali
effettivamente vanno a fare una
misurazione degli impatti a livello
ambientale sociale e di buon governo
essi contengono al loro interno quei
famosi 17 sostenibile vallo clan toschi
cui sentiamo parlare spesso almeno il
dubbio settore e sono quelli delle
nazioni unite quelle dell'azienda 20 30
pubblicata nel 2015
io di mestiere faccio alla fundraiser mi
occupo di raccolta fondi nel terzo
settore
e quando ho iniziato a occuparmi di
misurazione di impatto di valutazione
dell'impatto in ambito di strategie di
filantropia strategica ovviamente si
parlava ancora di una metodologia molto
di nicchia
costosa sicuramente è implementata
spesse volte in ambito internazionale o
comunque diciamo in maniera sperimentale
quando andavo a proporre ai miei clienti
di inserire implementare una teoria di
impatti teoria di cambiamento una
misurazione di impatto tante volte mi
veniva detto sì certo è molto
interessante però effettivamente qua in
italia
la vedo difficile
forse all'estero magari in inghilterra
in germania
oggi non è più così
anzi con la nuova legge del terzo
settore le cose stanno cambiando
ma comunque ogni volta che uno fa
riferimento a quelle che sono delle
innovazioni di questo tipo ci sono
ancora delle realtà che giustamente sono
intimorita e così ho pensato ma tra il
mondo della finanza
e la filantropia
esiste una maniera più etica di gestire
gli investimenti e cioè io quando mi
sono avvicinata a un altro attore che
poteva essere quello della finanza mi
sono resa conto che parlare
semplicemente di una finanza più etica
era molto riduttiva se ci fate caso
ovviamente di sostenibilità oggi si
parla tantissimo noi veniamo subissati
in continuazione ed effettivamente ci
rendiamo conto che le realtà non sono
così semplici sono molto più complessi
di quanto sembra ecco la finanza
sostenibile porta al suo interno queste
quattro realtà mi raccomando fate le
foto di alcune slide perché vi
serviranno in futuro per andare a
verificare quelli che sono in realtà da
scegliere la consob cioè quella realtà
che controlla i bilanci sociali dichiara
la finanza sostenibile è l'applicazione
del concetto di sviluppo sostenibile
dell'attività finanziaria che non siano
a carico del sistema ambientale è tanta
roba lo dice e la consob ma anche gli
attori coinvolti devono fare la
differenza perché gli attori coinvolti
che fanno accedono a tutti quelli che
sono i bond i bandi il pnr i crediti
finanziamenti per l'innovazione sociale
bene tutti questi devono fare la loro
dichiarazione di misurazione impatto
perché appunto la norma lo richiede e
quindi non è solamente un azione
pubblicitaria e quindi io vi dico che il
green and social impact bond il
washington serve assolutamente a niente
non ci porta da nessuna parte
serve alla base anche una dimensione di
valore prima di ogni valutazione di
impatto
effettivamente dobbiamo chiederci ma
alla base esiste un autentico pensiero
democratico cioè
effettivamente vanno a vedere oppure no
questi principi come la parità di genere
lo so la giustizia sociale
sono tutti argomenti che devono essere
al principio e poi deve esserci la
valutazione dell'impatto ed inoltre e se
serve un sistema dei pesi perché è un
indicatore po pesaro 10 o 20 e un 60 per
cento ma fa la differenza che cos'è la
finanza di impatto alla fine alla stessa
significato della finanza sostituire ma
ha una piccola differenza anzi grande
differenza si divide tra finanza
l'impatto in taxi e la finanza
semplicemente
da un lato abbiamo rendimento che vale
identico a quello del mercato dall'altra
parte invece il rendimento può essere
più basso perché viene preferito proprio
l'impatto ma quando nasce l'impatto
investi l'impatto in versi nasce nel
2006 proprio quando c'è stato il grande
crack del 2008 quando c'è stato proprio
il grande crac della della borsa ea
inizio secolo e in quell'occasione si
sono messi insieme tutti quegli attori
che hanno voluto capire come cambiare un
po le regole del gioco per la finanza
per renderla più etica per mantenere i
rendimenti alti o comunque normali ma
inserirli anche gli impatti sociali
anche questa è una slide che riporta
tutti quelli con gli spazi dove nella
finanza si includono o si escludono
alcuni punti per esempio la finanza per
per le armi e il vicino alla filantropia
vedete proprio segnalati questi due
nuovi e settori della finanza degli
impatti investing ma quali sono le masse
degli impatti investing quando nel 2008
si è iniziato a partire se partiti da 40
50 miliardi di dollari e il 15 anni sono
aumentati fino ad arrivare a mille
miliardi sono cifre astronomiche mi
rendo conto soprattutto in confronto ai
100 mila
guardi dei fondi di dollari di
investimento anche ci sono ma rispetto
alla finanza tradizionale che non
include alcun modo quelli che sono
veramente in piccolissima parte quelli
che possono essere di essi che ammonta a
1.500
trilioni di dollari si può fare di più
allora sì esistono gli investimenti dei
criteri sg e non sono pochi sono 35 3
trilioni che si aggiungono a questi 1500
io spero di farvi comprendere di quanto
in realtà ancora un impatto investing ha
un ruolo molto piccolo
egli si tratta di un cambiamento
culturale da fare nell'ambito della
finanza proprio per andare investire in
quelle realtà e in quelle società in
quelle imprese sociali società benefit e
di valore investito gli investitori
quindi facendo questa scelta vanno verso
un'economia più civile cioè l'impact
investment ha la possibilità di
trasformare
dall'interno proprio il sistema
capitalistico pure quello della homo
economicus
ma quali sono oggi gli attori
dell'impact investing sono cinque sono
veramente pochissimi in italia quindi di
cose da fare ci sono davvero tante ma
torniamo a noi che cosa possiamo fare io
voi noi tutti insieme per cambiare le
cose
di fatto è studiare affrontate da questa
tematica è una e una di quelle tematiche
che cambiano effettivamente percorsi
perché la finanza da parte di un mondo
potente
ti faccio l'esempio piccolino ma per 20
interessante da seguire è nota la borsa
dell'impatto sociale promosso da torino
social impact una realtà molto molto
interessante da seguire ed ed oggi
abbiamo anche il modello del payment by
rasul è un sistema complesso che non mi
sto a spiegare ma include la
collaborazione della pubblica
amministrazione del mondo profit del
terzo settore del fondo innovazione
sociale per creare progetti che vadano
verso
le necessità del bene comune dalla
sommità l'edilizia pubblica
all'innovazione tecnologica sono
coinvolti 22 comuni e nei prossimi anni
ne vedremo i risultati questo è il primo
modello venuto dalla nota d'inghilterra
applicato in italia
io abito in una via che ha non si può
definire una social state perché però è
una comunità di strada che si chiama per
leone insieme mese fa circa
siamo stati contattati nè a una realtà
che si chiama we went se una società
benefit è una start up e si occupa di
comunità energetiche comunità
energetiche avete idea di che cosa
significa significa e questo è il report
di legambiente che riporta che sono i
punti di verde non so se individuate
sono 100 in italia oggi che cosa una
comunità energetica la comunità
energetica ha a disposizione un tetto
molto grande dove si posiziona
ovviamente una una grande realtà
di di pannelli solari o scusatemi bene
questi vanno tutti distribuiti poi sui
vari componenti di un quartiere questa
realtà
potrebbe potrebbe poteva potrebbe essere
un esempio di investimento di impatto ma
purtroppo ancora acerbo come mercato
parte sempre con un modello dal basso e
cioè come un crowd funding e cioè sempre
da tutti voi
quando ero piccola a zurigo vidi una
scritta
immaginate che ci fosse una guerra e che
nessuno ci andava
anna morgano mela cambiato
immaginate che esistesse solo alla
finanza sostenibile e che tutti ci
vestissero grazie
[Applauso]
grazie